[Applause]  Rozier around the defensive Leonard in  the corner to McDaniels for three no  rebound goes to George the shot clock is  turned off we're tied at 117.  wall with plenty of time on the clock  here picked up by Rozier they go to  Leonard  sizing up his Defender five to shoot  step back for the lead hot damn Kawhi  Leonard puts the Clippers out in front  by two  foreign  you know what's interesting about that  play Paul George gave it up and he  pointed to get it to Kawaii which when  he's rolling he keeps the ball in his  hands isolates up front but he felt at  that time that this particular time the  possession that Kawhi had a better  option and he was patient  with his move got to the spot